are you worried that brexit would have
really fundamentally shaken people's
trust in the whole democratic process in
the UK well to be honest I think it's
been a long time coming in towns like
mine I think before we had the vote to
leave the EU we had a very sudden and
dramatic rise in support for UK
including amongst many people who would
never have dreamed of voting for openly
racist or far-right parties and before
that we had years of falling turnout
that we thought was apathy but actually
was a level of frustration even anger
with the political system that people
didn't feel really spoke for them or
understood their interests and so I
think this has been a long time coming
and Bret's it really was the sort of
final chance to get us to wake up and
listen my worry about the way that the
debate has gone in Parliament and in
politics over the last few years
especially the last few months is that
with attitudes hardening in Parliament
as well as public a number of my
constituents now feel that not only have
are they being told that they voted the
wrong way last time but they're also
being told that they are you know
essentially too stupid to have a say in
the future of the country and you know
the view from here couldn't be more
different there are people who voted
remain and leave having thought very
hard about it because they had feelings
about the European Union and about the
way that politics works that just simply
aren't being addressed and we're still
not addressing them and I think we are
facing a very real breach of trust
between politicians and many people who
voted in good faith and feel that we're
just not taking that seriously
it's interesting that you are saying
that MPs positions are hardening as well
on both sides of the debate I mean this
coming week of course MPs will be voting
again on Britain's adoptions nobody got
majority last time around I mean are you
worried that rather than kind of
reaching out for a compromise MPs are
actually becoming more entrenched in
their own positions
I think mp's are very like the public
actually and the part of the reason that
Parliament's gridlocked is because the
public is still gridlock so very
different views about what should happen
next but actually most people just like
most MPs
I think are willing to compromise
understand that this was a very close
vote and that although we're leaving
that doesn't mean that we're leaving in
the hardest way possible
you know I stood on a manifesto that
said that we should leave with a deal in
2017 and that was largely accepted by
people in Wigan and many other similar
constituencies the trouble is that what
we've had is the same as the public
we've had people on each extreme you
know on our side people who support
second referendum because they want to
remain on their side people who want to
leave with no deal who've been knocking
out all of the compromised options in
the middle and as a consequence we've
got to this point where we can't move
forwards now last week you saw a bit of
movement on that we started to
compromise and the option that came
closest because many of us did
compromise so winning a majority support
in Parliament was a customs union and I
think I hope what you're going to see
emerge tomorrow and over the next few
days is strong support across the Tory
and labour benches for a form of soft
brexit and then it's really up to the
Prime Minister is she willing to start
listening to those very different views
and those very different experiences
across the country or is she going to
drive this country to to the brink of no
deal or is she going to face the general
election you've been listening to what
you're saying now on the customs union
and also listening to what every
Thornbury was saying earlier about a
customs union why is it that you're
unable to vote for the withdrawal
agreement which effectively has a
customs union in it anyway if you're
trying to find a way through and a
compromise solution why not vote for the
Prime Minister's withdrawal agreement
well you know going into a transition
where you're still able to trade is
obviously extremely important and with
rural agreement passing would allow us
to do that it's why for six months now
I've been saying I'm trying to find a
way to vote for this the problem is the
lack of clarity about the future which
is why this week is really important
because if we can persuade the prime
minister to write those assurances into
the political declaration that
accompanies their withdrawal agreement
and given that on Friday they accepted
an amendment from Gareth Snell and
myself and others giving a role for
Parliament in those future stages and a
vote on what happens next then perhaps
you could start to see some movement I
have to
the Prime Minister has caused some
problems this week because by standing
saying she'll stand down when the
withdrawal agreement goes through which
was designed to reassure hardline Tory
MPs on her own side she's actually had
precisely the opposite effect on the
labor side because these guarantees that
she's currently making we have no idea
whether they'll be met by a new prime
minister a new Prime Minister obviously
wouldn't be bound by many of those
assurances and that has been the problem
all the way through this process the
Prime Minister is trying to play it both
ways but actually she's going to have to
decide does she tilt to the center and
form a majority consensus across
parliament in the country around a form
of soft brexit and enable us to move on
or is she going to continue pandering to
a small group of people in her own party
that's her choice only she can make it
and that's what I hope you know we'll be
able to to deal with this week because
you know for all of the talk from the
prime minister about the need to
compromise there is one person who
hasn't compromised all the way through
this process and that's why we're in the
mess that we're in and the frustration
that you heard in Whitstable is
absolutely what I've been hearing in
Wigan as well and we can't take much
more of this so just to really try and
pin you down there you mentioned the
amendment that you've been pushing
giving parliamentary parliamentarians
great to say on any day or the next
phase of talks so if that amendment goes
through would you then be prepared to
vote for the withdrawal agreement so the
government said on Friday that they will
accept that amendment we weren't able to
move it because the speaker didn't
select say it's just a technical
question the government has said that
they will write that into the meaningful
vote whenever it materializes again if
it does so that was a really really
welcomed move from the Prime Minister
very late but still very very long as
well if we could get if we could get if
we could get this this consensus around
the customs union written into the
political declaration if we could see a
prime minister really start to to move
and accept that these things matter
and and give some level of assurances
around the process around what happens
next then yes but the problem was on
Friday she stood at the despatch-box
lecturing MPs and still saying you know
the reason this hasn't moved is you and
actually what we need to see from her is
a completely different approach that
understands and respects that sounds
like Wigan have very different economic
situations than even perhaps Emily's
constituency and all of those different
parts have to be heard in what comes
next if she can do that she would start
to rebuild trust and people like me
would find it much easier to vote
through the withdrawal agreement and
move this country onto those next stages
of negotiations
Emily Phil Murray told me a few moments
ago that in her heart she wants to
remain what do you want in your heart
well I've always been clear with my
constituents I've never I've never lied
to them about it a campaign for remain I
still think it would be in Britain's
interest to remain in the European Union
but I do think we're at a moment now
where we have only bad options in front
of us frankly every option that we have
has downsides why because we had a
referendum we asked people to vote in
good faith and as you heard in
Whitstable as I heard at the football
yesterday in Wigan we are breaking our
democracy if we ask people to come
forward and express a view about the
future of the country and they take it
seriously and they participate in what
was the biggest democratic engagement
exercise in my lifetime and then we say
actually we'd like to try and overturn
the result of that before we've even
tried to implement it I think the
consequences of that will be very very
severe for decades to come and that's
why we've got to find a way to come
together and work through the middle of
this to see if we can find an economic
relationship with the EU going forward
after we leave that protects jobs in
towns like mine but also respects the
fact that people came out and expressed
a view we told them that they would be
heard and they should be